[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis guten abend und
herzlich willkommen was im sport
passiert ist erfahren sie von norbert
lehmann deutschland die wichtigen themen
heute
historischer prozess in frankreich 20
angeklagte stehen vor gericht weil sie
an den pariser anschlägen mit 130 toten
beteiligt gewesen sein sollen
warnung vor gefährlicher vierter corona
welle das robert koch institut fordert
die impfquote drastisch zu steigern
goldener tag für die deutschen
dressurreiter die mannschaft wird zum 25
mal europameister
es ist die terror nacht des 13 november
2015 die zum trauma frankreichs wird
eine serie verheerender anschläge in
paris seit heute müssen sich 20
angeklagte dafür vor gericht
verantworten
die us-kommandos schlugen damals am
späten freitagabend zu vor dem start de
france sprengten sich drei islamisten in
die luft während des länderspiels
frankreich gegen deutschland
weitere terroristen erschossen gäste in
bars und restaurants
die meisten opfer gab es im konzept
blockbutter klo insgesamt wurden 130
menschen getötet und 350 verletzt eine
arendt über den prozessauftakt als
beruf gibt er kämpfer des islamischen
staates an reue zeigt ja nicht der
hauptangeklagte salah abdel slum in dem
verfahren das am mittag unter großen
sicherheitsvorkehrungen
eröffnet wird aufgeklärt werden sollen
die hintergründe der attentate von 2015
jener novembernacht die tiefe wunden
gerissen hat
nun eine solche aussage zu hören
empfinden meine mandanten als eine
erneute direkte bedrohung das war eine
sehr schlimme erfahrung gleich zu beginn
aber so wird es wohl die nächsten monate
weitergehen
fast 1800 personen haben neben klage
eingereicht allein sie namentlich
aufzurufen wird die ersten beiden tage
in anspruch nehmen sie alle sollen im
prozess gebührenden raum erhalten über
das erlebte zu berichten
die terroristen schlugen gleich an
mehreren orten zu richteten im
konzertsaal wasser club ein blutbad an
feuerten auf gäste die auf den terrassen
der bars und restaurants saßen sprengten
sich vor dem fußballstadion in die luft
während frankreich gegen deutschland
spielte schakfeh jeder in frankreich
erinnert sich genau was er oder sie am
13 november 2015 gemacht hat was wir
rund um den prozess lesen hören und
sehen werden wird uns nicht unberührt
lassen
nicht nur die nebenkläger ein ganzes
land schaut nun auf den prozess den
viele auch als demokratische antwort auf
die barbarei bewährten berufskolleg was
ich von dem prozess erwarte ist dass er
uns alle stärkt uns als weltbürger
unsere französische zivilisation uns als
europäer
neun monate sind vorerst für das
verfahren angesetzt das schon jetzt als
historisch eingestuft wird
thomas walde in paris welche bedeutung
hat dieser jabr historische prozess für
frankreich
gilt als historisch zum einen wegen der
dimension der anschläge dann wären der
schieren größe dieses prozesses aber das
geht noch ein bisschen darüber hinaus
hier in paris ist die lesart dass die
terroristen nicht nur die französische
republik angegriffen haben sondern die
freiheitliche westliche lebensart
insgesamt und man wird es nun anders
machen bei der aufarbeitung als die
amerikaner beispielsweise nach nine
eleven mit ihren militärtribunale in
guantanamo man will hier auch zeigen
dass der demokratische rechtsstaat das
instrument ist um terrorismus wirksam
begegnen zu können selbst wenn dabei
oder vielleicht gerade
obwohl dabei
die die eigenen institutionen hier
mitunter in frage gestellt werden und
ihre schwächen vor diesen anschlägen man
hofft dass diese offene transparente art
des umgangs am ende dazu führt dass das
eine signalwirkung hat auch über
frankreich hinaus vielen dank für diese
einschätzung thomas walde
und wir bleiben in paris dorthin war
spd-kanzlerkandidat olaf scholz am
montag gereist heute wurde auch unions
kandidat armin laschet im elysée palast
von frank präsident max anfangen wir
brauchen mehr europa gegen den
terrorismus sagte laschet mit blick auf
den prozess um die anschlagserie 2015
laschet waren seiner funktion als
deutsch französischer kultur
bevollmächtigter in paris
zur pandemie für die ärmeren länder
sieht so aus bis jahresende können nur
für höchstens 20 prozent der menschen
dort corona impfstoffe geliefert werden
so die internationale kovacs initiative
in deutschland dagegen gibt es zwar
genug impfstoffe aber eine gesunde
impfbereitschaft
bundesweit haben 61,6 prozent der
bevölkerung eine vollständige impfung
bei der impfquote gibt es dabei ein
west-ost-gefälle
spitzenreiter ist bremen mit 71,7
prozent danach folgen das saarland und
schleswig holstein
am ende der liste thüring dann
brandenburg und schließlich ist nach wie
vor mit sachsen mit 52,7 prozent
insgesamt reichen die quoten nicht um
die vierte welle wirksam zu stoppen sagt
bundesgesundheitsminister sparen was tun
britta spiekermann
lange schlange vor einer kirche in
hamburg ein mobiles team bietet drinnen
schnelles unkompliziertes impfen die
zuletzt stagnierende impfquote soll
schnell steigen der herbst steht vor der
tür die vierte welle soll möglichst
gedämpft ablaufen
gute alternative als sie bei einem haus
hat da hätte ich noch länger warten
müssen das jetzt nicht so dass ich total
davon überzeugt bin ehrlich gesagt aber
ich bin jeder hat das recht selber zu
entscheiden und ob oder nicht ist für
mich in ordnung sich gegen die impfung
zu entscheiden ist für den sport nicht
in ordnung erbittet er dringt und will
den druck erhöhen müssen ab 11 oktober
selbst bezahlt werden sparen hält jetzt
auch einen lohnabzug für ungeimpfte die
in quarantäne müssen für gerechtfertigt
an der frage wird der test bezahlt wird
die der arbeitsausfall bezahlt bin ich
aber genauso klar sehe ich nicht ein
warum auf dauer andere zahlen sollen
wenn sich eben jemand und ich für die
kostenlose impfung entscheidet obwohl er
könnte heute auch einen schulterschluss
mit dem einzelhandel lebens statt
lockdown das motto der impfkampagne
erste erfolge gibt es bereits mehr als
100.000 impfdosen wurden in den
einkaufszentren verabreicht
niederschwellig beim einkaufen auf dem
weg quasi in der innenstadt es drohe
eine pandemie der ungeimpften warnt
ergo-chef wila und malt ein düsteres
bild wenn wir die aktuellen quoten ist
drastisch steigern dann kann die
aktuelle kältewelle im herbst einen
fulminanten verlauf nehmen hamburg und
das 2g modellen hier gilt zutritt nur
für geimpfte und genießen nicht geimpfte
müssen draußen bleiben der druck auf sie
sich impfen zu lassen wächst
schauen wir auf die wichtigen zahlen die
die korona maßnahmen bestimmen mit
insgesamt 82 7 es die sieben tage
incidents etwas gesunken in absoluten
zahlen wurde das virus seit dem vortag
bei 13.500 65 personen nachgewiesen
inzwischen geht es vor allem um die
auslastung der kliniken
638 menschen kamen neu mit symptomen ins
krankenhaus
damit steigt die sogenannte
hospitalisierung rate leicht auf 179
fälle pro 100.000 1
um die menschen in deutschland zum
impfen zu bewegen braucht es
verständliche informationen so
verständlich dass man auch menschen
erreicht die schwierigkeiten mit dem
lesen und schreiben haben das sind rund
6,2 millionen erwachsene in deutschland
zum weltalphabetisierungstag ein blick
auf das thema von roman leskovar den
impf aufklärungsbogen findet harald kaul
heute noch schwer verständlich
jahrzehntelang konnte der anfang 50
jährige nicht richtig lesen und
schreiben in der schule hatte sich
durchgemogelt die kogit impfung hat er
von einem arzt erhalten der sein problem
kennt viele betroffene aber würden aus
scham auf die spritze verzichten das
wirklich so schlimm diese ängste dass
jemand mit krieg das ja nicht lesen und
schreiben kann und dass man ihr handelt
wird und und diskriminiert wird
schauspieler arbeitet im neuköllner
gesundheits kolleg mediziner und
therapeuten kümmern sich hier auch um
erwachsene mit lese und schreib
problemen das interesse an corona infos
groß meist gehen die mitarbeiter in
bildungseinrichtungen nehmen sich zeit
für aufklärung zeit die betroffene wenn
sie sich zum arzt trauben dort ja selten
erhielten
häufig berichtet dass sie schlechte
erfahrungen gemacht haben und
[Musik]
gut finden wenn sie dann ausführlich von
uns beraten werden probleme allerdings
von den über sechs millionen betroffenen
erwachsenen sind derzeit nicht mal ein
prozent in lese und schreib posen
umfassende beratung auch zu corona ist
so nur schwer möglich die alpha mobil
mitarbeiter versuchen bundesweit für die
maßnahmen zu werden unser ziel ist es
wenn wir menschen auf der straße
ansprechen sie dazu motivieren noch mal
lesen schreiben besser zu lernen das
funktioniert nicht nur über die
betroffenen selbst sondern auch über das
mitwissen umfeld harald kaul hat lese
und schreibkurse besucht jetzt ist der
lärm botschafter will andere betroffene
unterstützen natürlich auch wenn sie
fragen zur kurve impfung haben
wie können weitere menschen aus
afghanistan in sicherheit gebracht
werden dazu war us-außenminister blinken
gerade zu gesprächen in doha und ist
jetzt in deutschland auf dem us
luftwaffenstützpunkt im pfälzischen
ramstein wo viele afghaninnen und
afghanen nach ihrer rettung erst mal
hingeflogen wurden traf sich blinken mit
bundesaußenminister maß beide sind
besorgt über die übergangsregierung der
islamistischen taliban hat jetzt ja
wieder meyer
von dor heute mittag dann weiter nach
ramstein der amerikanische außenminister
blinken dankt den mitarbeitern hier für
ihren unermüdlichen einsatz bei der
evakuierung tausender afghanen und
ortskräfte beim anschließenden treffen
mit außenminister maß betonten beide
eine bemerkenswerte partnerschaft wie
weiter in afghanistan
darum ging es bei der folgenden video
konferenz mit amtskollegen aus 20
staaten
ein weiteres thema wie umgehen mit der
neuen taliban regierung gestern wurde
bekannt dass das übergangskabinett
ausschließlich aus männern der
islamischen miliz besteht der neue
innenminister der hardliner
siradschuddin hakkani gründer einer
terrorgruppe er zählt zu den
meistgesuchten männern des fbi für die
grünen ist klar gespräche ja geld nein
diese tat wie man wolle nicht die wollen
und deshalb muss man versuchen mit in zu
retten im gespräch mit ihm zu retten was
noch zu retten ist vor einer stunde dann
pressekonferenz in ramstein beide
minister zeigen sich besorgt über die
neue regierung wollen aber alles tun um
humanitäre hilfe vor ort und weitere
ausreisen zu ermöglichen los falls diese
flüge müssen weiter das land verlassen
dürfen und wir arbeiten jeden tag daran
dass das möglich ist
wir fordern aber auch gemeinsam mit
anderen partnern den schutz
grundlegender menschen- und vor allem
frauenrechte und eine regierung die
tatsächlich alle gesellschaftliche
gruppen einbeziehen wenig optimismus
heute aber zu gesprächen mit den taliban
um weitere evakuierungen zu ermöglichen
gibt es derzeit kaum alternativen
mit dem umstrittenen sogenannten
sicherheitsgesetz gehen die behörden in
hongkong massiv gegen oppositionelle vor
jetzt wurden wieder vier festgenommen
die frauen und die drei männer gehören
zur sogenannten hongkong alias sie
hatten sich geweigert vertrauliche daten
und finanzunterlagen von
menschenrechtsgruppen herauszugeben die
allianz hatte die kerzen andachten
organisiert bei dem jährlich
hunderttausende an die niederschlagung
der chinesischen demokratiebewegung im
jahr 1989 erinnert
wir blicken auf die griechischen inseln
katholische bischöfe und
bundestagsabgeordnete haben an die
bundesregierung appelliert von dort
mindestens 14.000 weitere schutzsuchende
aufzunehmen vor einem jahr war das
überfüllte flüchtlingslager moria auf
lesbos niedergebrannt tausende menschen
mussten vor den flammen fliehen es gab
keine toten oder verletzten flüchtlinge
selbst hatten das feuer gelegt um eine
verlegung aus dem lager zu erzwingen wie
sieht es heute dort aus annette
hilsenbeck
wo das lager moria stand zeigt uns dass
lara elf monate hat er mit seiner
familie dort gelebt ist es brannte und
sie wie tausende andere auf der straße
saßen danach ins übergangslager car at t
kamen
dort ist das besser weil die sicherheit
gutes und es gibt ärzte
im übergangslager gibt es inzwischen
wohncontainer genug wasser und strom die
zustände besser als das elend der ersten
monate als die menschen inständig
überfluteten zelten hausten es kaum
sanitäre anlagen gab ein neues
geschlossenes lager sollte eigentlich
längst hier stehen von der eu finanziert
das scheiterte bisher am widerstand der
inselbewohner die zahl derer die aus der
türkei übers meer kommen ist derweil
erheblich gesunken kritiker machen die
griechische küstenwache für die
gesunkenen zahlen verantwortlich sie
greife flüchtlingsboote auf dem meer auf
und schicke sie zurück
uns liegen fotos und videos von solchen
illegalen zurückweisungen so genannten
push becks vor die sind inzwischen zur
methode des griechischen staates
geworden die eu beschäftigt sich jetzt
allmählich mit diesen zurückweisen
die griechische regierung verschärft
derweil ihre flüchtlingspolitik so droht
etwa hilfsorganisationen eine geldstrafe
wenn sie flüchtlingsbooten ohne
beteiligung der küstenwache helfen jetzt
im lager karate sind haben es geschafft
nach europa den dreck anderer über das
meer über die grenze macht griechenland
künftig schwerer
in dresden hat ein prozess gegen
mutmaßliche linksextremisten und eine
mutmaßliche linksextremisten begonnen
sie sollen gezielt menschen aus der
rechten szene in sachsen und thüringen
zusammengeschlagen und teils
lebensgefährlich verletzt haben
anführerin der gruppe soll eine 26
jährige studentin sein mit ihr sind drei
männer angeklagt
laut bundesanwaltschaft haben sie die
opfer intensiv ausgespäht und die
angriffe professionell geplant den
vorwurf sie seien teil einer kriminellen
vereinigung weist die verteidigung
zurück
vor rund drei jahren hatten sich
braunkohle gegner innen in baumhäusern
verschanzt sie wollten den hambacher
forst erhalten die behörden räumten das
camp zu unrecht urteilte jetzt das
verwaltungsgericht köln die räumung sei
damals mit brandschutzvorschriften
begründet worden das sei nur
vorgeschoben gewesen erklärte das
gericht tatsächlich sei es um die
entfernung der protestierenden gegangen
rwe wollte damals den wald für den
kohleabbau fans inzwischen ist die
rodung vom tisch
beim bis zu reiten beim deutschen
dressurreiter sind die reiterin auf die
jacke nach den goldmedaillen bei den
olympischen sommerspielen in tokio geht
es bei der europameisterschaft in hagen
munter weiter die dressur equipe hat zum
25 seit 1965 den em mannschaftstitel
nach deutschland geholt vier strahlende
europameisterinnen nach zwei
wettkampftagen in der
mannschaftsentscheidung am dienstag
hatten dorothee schneider und helen
langehanenberg die deutsche equipe auf
rang zwei geräten heute dann der
auftritt von isabelle werth die
mannschafts-olympiasiegerin zeigt midway
gold eine leistung im viereck mit der
sie selbst sehr zufrieden ist die aber
bei den preisrichtern sehr
unterschiedlich bewertet wird
kopfschütteln über die 77 71
prozentpunkte der französischen
richterin dennoch bringt wert
deutschland in führung vor
großbritannien schluss reiterin und
doppel olympia siegerin jessica von
bredow wandel und ihre stute der lehrer
anschließend mit dressur in perfektion
die beiden zeigen höchstschwierigkeiten
mit einer überragenden leichtigkeit und
erhalten in diesem grand prix 84,0 99
prozentpunkte rekord europameister
deutschland mit dem 25 gold
großbritannien silber dänemark gewinnt
bronze
erfolgreicher start für deutschland auch
bei der straßenrad-wm in trient im mixed
team zeitfahren gab es silber ebenso für
antonia niedermayer im einzelzeitfahren
der juniorinnen
zum fußball die deutsche u21 mannschaft
feiert den nächsten erfolg in der em
qualifikation nach dem auftaktsieg gegen
san marino gewannen der europameister
gestern am 3 2 1 gegen lettland und
bleibt tabellenführer der gruppe b
bundestrainer stefan kunz musste nur
anfänglich korrigierend eingreifen nach
einem frühen gegentreffer war die
dfb-elf nach 25 minuten wieder in der
spur der erst 16 jahre alte josef amoco
mit dem 1 1 ausgleich
deutschland spielbestimmend angelo
stiller traf noch vor der halbzeit zur
verdienten führung die marco kurz nach
der pause zum 3 1 endstand ausbaute der
durch den jahrgangs wechsel neu
formierte europameister macht schon
jetzt lust auf mehr
[Applaus]
das was vom sport dankeschön norbert und
es ist mittwoch und das heißt die
lottozahlen sind gezogen die
gewinnzahlen lauten 13 21 23 30 41 44
und die superzahl 3 weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und im
zdf text auf seite 5 157
kommen noch zum wetter ist bleibt zwar
morgen warm aber es kommen erste
gewitter auf und die details dazu hat
gleich ist denn terry für sie um 21 45
können sie hier das heute journal sehen
mit christian sievers schön abend ihn
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter ja in der
kommenden nacht gibt es im südwesten
schon den ersten regen möglich wird es
mit diesem tiefes zieht zwar weiter nach
nordosten aber die kaltfront erreicht
uns und so werden vor allem am
nachmittag gewitter ausgelöst allerdings
kommt immer noch warme luft zu uns in
der kommenden nacht also im südwesten
wolken verdichtung und teilweise erste
schauer nach osten hin ist es aber stern
klar mit tiefsten werten bis acht grad
nach osten hin und 18 grad am oberrhein
ähnlich mild ist es dann ganz im westen
bei 16 grad morgen im osten deutschlands
viel sonnenschein und auch richtung
bayern aber im tagesverlauf werden die
schauer kräftiger vor allem im westen
dann teils mit starkregen 20 bis 30
liter in kurzer zeit sind möglich in der
nähe von gewittern die temperaturen
erreichen höchstwerte von 28 grad im
nordwesten deutschlands aber häufig
haben wir werte zwischen 24 und 27 grad
die kommenden tage am freitag weitere
schauer und gewitter im westen und im
norden bis 27 grad samstag ebenfalls
wechselhaft nicht mehr ganz so warm und
sonntag aber wieder deutlich ruhiger ein
schöner amt